in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for June 4th, on which we commemorate the venerable
Sophia, Blessed Sophia, came from Aeinos, Thrace, Married and the mother of six children,
the cares of her household did not, however, distract her from the duties of Piety, and
she did not miss an office in the church.
According to the house she would spend her best part of the night in prayer.
When her children died, she gave away all her possessions to the poor and became the
adoptive mother of those widows who were without support.
Being delivered from every care, saved that of pleasing God, she spent the rest of her life
in a perpetual fast, taking no sustenance except bread and water.
Others flowed ceaselessly from her eyes and the psalms were constantly on her lips.
She showed a measureless humility even to people of the lowest condition, and all her care
was to distribute alms, preferring to deprive herself of necessities rather than let the needy
leave with empty hands.
She had a large stone jar full of wine, which she distributed liberally to the poor.
The wine in the jar never decreased, and, while she kept this miracle a secret, it continued.
But as soon as she told one of her kin of it, the wine began to decrease naturally.
Attributing the withdrawal of divine favor to her own unworthiness, the saint increased
her mortifications to the extent that her body, withered and reduced to its last extremity,
was scarcely still breathing.
She lived thus in God-pleasing labors for 34 years, always remaining a laywoman, and fell
asleep at the age of 53, shortly after receiving monastic profession.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.